One thing I like to mention really quick is how I work,
in terms of what things I have open.
This is something that I always try to get guys who work with me,
at, I'd rather not have a month to do.
Got your browser, you're running your things in it.
And you've got your editor with your code in it.
Your browsers got some pictures and some text.
If your screen is big enough, I like to have them side by side, but
sometimes that's not the case.
Something people often neglect is having your terminal nearby.
I almost always, like when I'm doing app engine or
my own stuff, run the app server auto terminal so you can see the logs.
If you're developing, without being able to see your logs, there's so
much stuff you're going to miss.
I find many, many bugs just by using my website as in developing, and
watching how the, how the logs goes.
Because many times there's an error that you're not even aware of that could be
a big deal in production.
You could have fixed it in five seconds if
you had just noticed the logs scrolling weird.
An, another important thing, and this is one of my frustrations in App Engine
right now, is it's critical if you're writing code that writes to a database,
but the queries that you're running are printed to the log.
I've kind of tried different strategies of hacking my app engine to print
every time it runs a query, because if you've got some complicated setup with
your database and your cache, and your mem cache, and maybe a local cache, and
all sorts of things, you want to make sure it's working.
And I know when I'm developing I often introduce bugs that has somehow prevent
something from being cached properly.
And if I am browsing along and
I see all these database queries scrolling by that shouldn't be,
that's a sign that something is broken.
And I want to make sure generally that every page I run doesn't hit
the database unless absolutely required.
If I see a query running that shouldn't be,
you know, I can catch it by just having the log open.
Try to get in the habit of when your switch from your editor to your browser
that you instead switch from your editor to your browser plus a terminal, so
you can see things working.
You start to get a sense for how the logs scrolls when your
website's working normally, so when it deviates, you can detect it faster.
You'll save yourself a lot of heartache doing it that way.
Now, I'd like to move on to how we actually built some of these
websites that I've been referring to.